[Musique]
pour nous c'était une évidence l'on ne
peut absolument pas se permettre d'avoir
une année blanche
nous finançons à la fois de la recherche
à travers des appels d'offres ces deux
centres de recherche aux jeunes
chercheurs qui sont financés par l'afm
téléthon et donc pas la gêner mais c'est
aussi des laboratoires que nous
soutenons et qui ne peuvent pas se
permettre d'être une année sans
ressources
et puis on a aussi une part de nos
ressources qui sont dédiées à
l'accompagnement des malades
on a beaucoup de contacts avec nos
bénévoles sur le terrain avec l'ensemble
des bénévoles dont je rappelle qu'ils
sont rouges de 250000 chaque année à se
mobiliser
on a proposé des choses qu vite
compatible puis confinement compatibles
concrètement sur le terrain ça va se
traduire par des drive des click and
collect comme ça on est bien à la page
et puis de la visibilité de l'affichage
je suis d'une nature positive et
optimiste je vais parler évidemment plus
de mai et ce point là le téléthon est un
événement de ce dernier unique au monde
à la fois par son ampleur aussi par ses
résultats et nous avons de belles
victoires thérapeutique encore dans
cette année j'ai un retour des
spectateurs à bien suivre cette édition
2020 parce que c'est une manière de leur
rendre compte aussi de tout ce dont on
est capable grâce à leur mobilisation